[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen neben mehr für den
sport norbert lehmann
blicken wir auf die themen heute im
überblick
mit tempo richtung ampel schon ende
november wollen sich spd grüne und fdp
einig sein vor allem bei klima und
finanzen drohen aber konflikte
eu gipfel mit spannungen im streit mit
polen fordern mehrere staaten konsequenz
kanzlerin merkel setzt auf dialog und
herbststurm über deutschland orkanböen
verursachen auf der strasse und der
schiene erhebliche probleme
schon in der woche ab dem 6 dezember
soll olaf scholz zum neuen bundeskanzler
gewählt werden ambitioniert ist der
zeitplan von spd grünen und fdp denn bis
dahin müssen die koalitionsverhandlungen
ja durch sein und dabei haben sie heute
erst begonnen am kommenden mittwoch geht
es in die details da beginnen die 22
arbeitsgruppen mit ihren verhandlungen
bis zum 10 november sollen sie dann
positionspapiere von finanzen bis
außenpolitiker arbeiten als grundlage
für den koalitionsvertrag der soll dann
ende november stehen so der plan lasst
bohnsack
die äußeren umstände am verhandlungsort
waren heute eher widrig drinnen aber
verbreiten spd grüne und fdp optimismus
und überraschen mit einem ambitionierten
zeitplan die koalitionsverhandlungen
sollen deutlich früher als bisher
geplant beendet werden weil wir sehr
ehrgeizig sind und ende des monats
november ein vertragswerk auch vorliegen
haben wollen dass es uns ermöglicht in
der woche vom 6 dezember einen
bundeskanzler für die bundesrepublik
deutschland zu wählen und eine
bundesregierung zu bilden ein straffer
zeitplan also für die 22
verhandlungsgruppen die zudem weder an
den wochenenden noch bis tief in die
nacht arbeiten sollen sie tragen die
volle verantwortung für die ergebnisse
die arbeitsgruppen haben den klaren
auftrag bekommen dass konflikte dort
geklärt werden sollen also man kennt das
ja aus anderen verhandlungen auch dass
es dann am ende schluss papiere von
arbeitsgruppen gibt wo 20.30 klammern
drin sind die denn in der
hauptverhandlung runde geklärt werden
sollen da haben wir explizit gesagt es
soll in den arbeitsgruppen sollen
konflikte geklärt werden an den
beschlüssen die bereits im sondierungs
papier festgehalten sind soll in den
koalitionsverhandlungen nicht mehr
gerüttelt werden dort geht es dann aber
um die wirklichen knackpunkte wie zum
beispiel die steuer und finanzpolitik
ist auch nicht die aufgabe von
sondierungen zu allen fachlichen themen
schon lösungen zu präsentieren sondern
das ist aufgabe dann der
koalitionsverhandlungen und der
arbeitsgruppen dafür lösung zu finden
und auch themen zu diskutieren
kommenden mittwoch beginnen die
verhandlungsgruppen mit ihrer arbeit zu
tun gibt es noch reichlich
ein ehrgeiziger zeitplan zur
regierungsbildung also andrea maurer
warum läuft es zwischen spd grünen und
fdp etwa so reibungslos
ja also zumindest nach außen der fdp
chef christian lindner der kam hier
gerade raus und sagte wir haben uns auf
den weg gemacht der
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen hat
gesagt das kriegen wir alles hin
tatsächlich erzielt derzeit plant er
hier heute präsentiert wurde auf
maximale effizienz mein eindruck war
dass man damit versucht sich selbst zu
motivieren aber natürlich setzt man sich
und die eigene partei damit auch massiv
unter druck kanzler scholz rund um die
rund um nikolaus das ist nun das ziel
für den hat das insofern charme als er
dann am 16 und 17 dezember als kanzler
zum eu-gipfel nach brüssel reisen könnte
wie gravierend allerdings tatsächlich
die streit und knackpunkte noch sind und
ob der sprint der nun hier hingelegt
werden soll tatsächlich gelingt das wird
sich spätestens auf der zielgeraden in
der november anfang dezember zeigen denn
es müssen ja auch noch die parteien
zustimmen bei den grünen ist eine
digital gestützte urabstimmung geplant
die fdp plant einen sonderparteitag und
die spd spd will am montag darüber
sprechen wie ein interner zeitplan für
eine zustimmung aussieht ob das also
dann tatsächlich ein sprint ist oder
vielleicht nicht sogar eher ein
hürdenlauf das wird sich also zeigen
dankeschön für diese einordnung andrea
maurer
und wenn sie mehr wissen wollen über den
stand der koalitionsverhandlungen zum
beispiel genaueres über die größten
knackpunkte zwischen den parteien können
sie das online nachlesen in unserer zdf
heute
noch aber ist die amtierende
bundeskanzlerin am zug und so ist angela
merkel derzeit auf ihrem wohl letzten eu
gipfel und versucht dort nochmal streit
zu schlichten zwischen den staats und
regierungschefs und polens
ministerpräsident moravek sie die
auseinandersetzung dreht sich um die
frage nach der rechtsstaatlichkeit in
polen soll die eu hier einen harten
sanktionskurs fahren oder lieber den
dialog mit warschau suchen und dann geht
es beim gipfel auch noch um die stark
steigenden energiepreise einige eu
länder setzen auf hilfen für verbraucher
andere fordern tiefgreifende reformen
auf dem gasmarkt von acryl ein gipfel
zweimal streit und immer zwei seiten
eine will handeln eine abwarten bei den
energiepreisen will spanien handelsstadt
er wisse ja nie die spanische regierung
wären da gerne schneller aber hier in
brüssel in der eu sind muss schritte
langsamer als wir uns das glück
das land spürt so wie die ganze eu
hohe energiepreise industrie genauso wie
dienstleister und verbraucher jedes
mitglied darf schon preise deckeln und
steuern senken aber den strommarkt umbau
und gas gemeinsam kaufen nicht mit
deutschland ich denke dass wir besonnen
reagieren sollten wir in deutschland
werden das jedenfalls tun dass wir den
markt nicht vollkommen ausschalten
sollten handeln oder abwarten dieselbe
frage in sachen rechtsstaat polens
premier reizte das eu-parlament und
rudert nicht zurück
institutionen die sich recht wo sie kein
recht haben zu entscheiden sie nehmen
sich kompetenzen richtungen kein gangs
vertrag die clubs und potenziell in
diesen bereichen habe polens recht
vorrang vor dem recht der eu für die
meisten ist das ein verstoß gegen eu
verträge doch nur die niederlande
fordern heute zu handeln und geld zu
sparen ich kann mir nur schwer
vorstellen wie das viele neue geld aus
dem aufbau von polen zur verfügung
gestellt werden soll wenn das nicht
gelöst
die bundeskanzlerin will nicht drohen
sondern reden es ist vielleicht die
letzte gipfel sie geht ihnen an wie die
106 davor
die eu will polen zum einlenken bringen
bei der rechtsstaatlichkeit anne
gellinek dialog oder druck auf was
werden die staats und
regierungschefinnen und chefs letztlich
setzen das war schon bemerkenswert wie
nachdenklich und wie ernsthaft besorgt
sich viele der ankommenden
gipfelteilnehmer hier zur lage in polen
geäußert haben trotzdem bleibt der
eindruck dass die staats und
regierungschefs kein interesse daran
haben den streit mit polen weiter zu
eskalieren
der einzige der öffentlich über die
kürzung von geldern gesprochen hat war
der niederländer mark rutte alle anderen
blieben da sehr vorsichtig kanzlerin
merkel mahnte man müsse auch wege finden
wie man wieder zusammenkommen wollte und
die führten eben nicht über
gerichtsverfahren wo man sich
gegenseitig verklagt die sorge der
gipfelrunde ist wohl auch dass wenn man
jetzt zu hart gegen polen vorgeht und
zum beispiel gelder aus dem eu haushalt
kürzt das sich dann andere europäische
länder mit polen solidarisieren könnten
und möglicherweise eine blockadepolitik
auf anderen feldern der eu zum beispiel
dem klimaschutz anstrengen könnten
außerdem wäre eine vertiefte spaltung
zwischen ost und west die folge das ist
brandgefährlich sagen viele und deshalb
wird es heute abend wohl viele deutliche
worte geben an den polnischen
premierminister morawski garniert aber
mit einem angebot zum dialog dankeschön
nach borstel anne gellinek
blicken wir auf die aktuelle corona lage
in deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 16.000 77 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages
3695 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incident steigt auf
85,6 vollständig geimpft sind
hierzulande mittlerweile fast 55
millionen menschen das sind 66 prozent
der gesamtbevölkerung
vollständig geimpfte erkranken deutlich
seltener schweren cupid 19 als
ungeimpfte zurzeit ist jedoch zu
beobachten dass auf die intensivstation
in deutschland etwa zehn prozent der
korona patientinnen und patienten
geimpft sind und diese so genannten impf
durchbrüche nehmen zu woran liegt das
elisabeth schmidt ist der frage
nachgegangen
in diesem seniorenheim in wolfsburg sind
fast alle gegen das corona virus geimpft
bewohner wie mitarbeiter und trotzdem
wurden im heim 3 doppelt geimpfte krank
leider hatten wir bei wenigen sehr
wenigen
bewohnerinnen und bewohner auch ein impf
durchbruch und in einem fall sogar mit
einem todesfall rein statistisch kommt
es bei den über 60-jährigen zurzeit am
häufigsten zu impf durchbrechen gut die
hälfte der erkrankten in dieser gruppe
war geimpft allerdings sind in dieser
altersgruppe insgesamt auf gut 85
prozent geimpft die andere hälfte der
erkrankten rekrutiert sich aus denn
gerade mal 15 prozent die nicht geimpft
sind
ein statistisches phänomen also je mehr
menschen geimpft sind desto größer ist
auch ihr anteil bei den impf
durchbrüchen auch auf den
intensivstationen steigt die zahl der im
durchbrüche etwa zehn prozent der
patienten hier sind geimpft die meisten
von ihnen über 60 jahre die
älteren personen haben auch häufiger
schwere begleiterkrankungen die auch
einen schweren krankheitsverlauf
begünstigen bei einer reaktion viele der
jüngeren götzer da die sich tatsächlich
trotz impfung nach effizienten merken
das gar nicht es sind die älteren
menschen die medizinern die meisten
sorgen bereiten zusätzlich ist es aber
natürlich so dass ein teil der
bevölkerung ja schon im januar und
februar abschließend geimpft war also
insbesondere dass die hochrisiko
patienten aber auch medizinisches
personal bei denen ist jetzt also die
abgeschlossene impfung schon über ein
halbes jahr her sodass jetzt eben auch
booster impfung wichtig sind die
impfstoffe wirken gegen die delta
variante des corona virus etwa zehn
prozent schlechter trotzdem schützen sie
vor schweren verläufen und den meisten
fällen auch bei impf durchbrüchen in
russland steigen die korona zahlen
weiter massiv an jetzt hat die
hauptstadt moskau einen neuen lockdown
angekündigt ab ende oktober müssen die
meisten geschäfte für eine woche lang
wieder schließen genauso wie schulen und
kindergärten
präsident putin hatte für diese zeit
bereits landesweite betriebsferien
verordnet russland registrierte heute
mehr als 36.000 kroner neuinfektionen so
viele wie noch nie
unsere welt wird immer digitaler immer
mehr systeme sind miteinander vernetzt
und dadurch sind wir auch angreifbarer
im neuen lagebericht schätzt die
zuständige bundesbehörde die situation
als kritisch ein cyber kriminelle würden
immer professioneller
das ergebnis blockierte systeme gestörte
abläufe in betrieben und große
finanzielle verluste durch erpressung
klaus brodbeck mit einzelheiten
lahmgelegt von cyberkriminellen die
stadtverwaltung schwerin die
computersysteme am boden der
verwaltungsbetrieb praktisch auch monate
kann das noch gehen wegen angriffen wie
diesem spricht das bundesamt für
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
von der leyen stufe rot
erstens eine deutliche
professionalisierung der
cyberkriminalität
zweitens die zunehmende digitale
vernetzung und drittens weite
verbreitung gravierender schwachstellen
in it produkten
die bedrohung durch schadprogramme
wächst rasant
144 millionen neue varianten seit 2009
10 + 22% an einem einzigen tag im
februar wurden
553.000 neue entdeckt schäden durch
erpressungen sogenannte ransomware plus
360 prozent diese menschen wäre die die
fängt an ihre systeme zu verschlüsseln
und irgendwann geht nichts mehr weil
alle inhalte sind verschlüsselt und dann
kommt in der regel die lösegeldforderung
für die entschlüsselung angreifer sitzen
meist in russland selber attacken gelten
als übliches mittel von moskaus
interessenpolitik wir sind fest
überzeugt dass vieles aus
dem bereich kommt herunter gefallen nach
einer cyberattacke derzeit auch die
server in witten nrw immer öfter stehlen
angreife in it-systemen gespeicherte
persönliche daten erpressen damit
zusätzlich bürger patienten kunden die
gefahr nimmt zu
der erste heftige herbststurm des jahres
ist über deutschland hinweggefegt in der
nacht ging es im südwesten los in einem
breiten band vom saarland aus zum
orkanartige böen über die mieter dort
deutschlands bis in die östlichen
bundesländer
aber auch jenseits dieses bandes
verursachte der sturm heftige schäden
und probleme im bahnverkehr und auf den
straßen thomas konzern berichtet
nein nicht nebel behindert hier die
sicht sondern sand von den äckern über
das land brandenburg gebiet der große
herbststurm eine gefahr für autofahrer
vor allem auf brücken hier über den
rhein bei speyer vom gas gehen wenn
rasend schnelle naturkräfte kommen
ratsam besonders für lkw
die folgen kilometer langer stau hier
zum glück aber keine verletzten
hindernisse stadt freie bahn auch
vielerorts im zugverkehr jedes mal heißt
es aussteigen bitte
alternativen nutzen und an bahnhöfen
warten lange warten entsprechend lang
und ratlos die gesichter in nordrhein
westfalen war zeitweise sogar der
komplette fernbahnverkehr eingestellt
[Musik]
schauen was los ist etwa in hamburg
bangen ob es das eigene parkende auto
getroffen hat oder das haus überall im
land gab es verletzte aber vor allem
sachschäden
insgesamt also verliefen eher glimpflich
der erste kräftige herbststurm
2021 dass er den verkehr
durcheinanderwirbelte bleibt aber noch
spürbar
vor allem für bahnreisende
deshalb an den hauptbahnhof in köln das
ist für uns eher ariane güdel ariane wie
sieht es denn derzeit aus für
bahnreisende
ja also normal läuft hier noch gar
nichts ist der bahnverkehr läuft so
langsam wieder an aber ist noch ziemlich
chaotisch lange schlangen vor dem info
point wirklich die ganzen damit hunderte
von menschen die wissen wollen ob es
weitergeht wie es weitergeht die bahn
mitarbeiter geben sich alle mühe
verteilen kostenlos kaffee aber der
ansturm ist schon ziemlich groß und auf
der anzeigentafel sieht man dass viele
züge in alle richtungen komplett
ausfallen der regionalverkehr stark
eingeschränkt verspätung haben
eigentlich alle züge die bahn hat ja
zugesichert dass die tickets weiterhin
gültig sind sieben tage lang aber was
nützt das wenn man hier gestrandet ist
und weiter muss oder auch will und das
ist ja auch nicht nur hier in köln so
sondern auch in anderen knotenpunkten
wie zb in frankfurt wo der verkehr
richtung süden stockte oder auch gar
nicht läuft und auch richtung wien und
deshalb hat die bahn noch eine hotline
eingerichtet wo man sich kostenlos eine
sonderheit kleidung man sich kostenlos
informieren kann und das kann man
eigentlich auch wirklich nur jedem raten
der auch morgen früh unterwegs sein will
sich zu informieren im internet und per
telefon
weil die bahn kann noch nicht sagen wann
der verkehr wieder reibungslos laufen
wird chaos also an den bahnhöfen
dankeschön marie anne gude und
wir kommen zum sport zur
fußball-champions-league und aber der
gesetz aufregung beim bayern ja
allerdings den trainer julian nagelsmann
der ist trotz zweifacher impfung an
corona erkrankt war beim spiel gestern
abend in lissabon nicht auf dem platz
und wird es auch am samstag gegen
hoffenheim nicht sein aus dem
hotelzimmer sei das 14 0 gegen benfica
mit einem herausragenden die häuser nach
frustrierender em und demütigen dem
treffen der bayern fans hat nissan die
kurve zum gefeierten matchwinner
gekriegt weltklasseleistung in lissabon
vor den augen von nagelsmann des dino
toppmöller wirbel seine entwickler mit
einem selbstvertrauen das ihm im sommer
komplett abhandengekommen
für solche szenen haben die bayern ihm
verpflichtet nachdem neue als ein
überlegenes team bei zwei kontern vor
einem rückstand bewahrte ist es endlich
soweit sein zauber die bayern mit einem
kunstvollen freistoß mit 1 0 in führung
kurz darauf führen sie nach eigentor
everton mit 2 zu 0 dann wieder
tänzerische leichtigkeit seine form 13 0
von robert lewandowski
zum 4 0-endstand trifft dann noch einmal
na klar wir äußern
erfolgsverwöhnte bayern siegen wolfsburg
dagegen muss den nächsten rückschlag
einstecken und kann auch im siebten
pflichtspiel nacheinander nicht gewinnen
der vfl unterliegt auswärts bei rb
salzburg mit 1 3 und ist jetzt
gruppenletzter ja und alle spiele und
alle tore des dritten champions league
spiel tags können sie sich bei uns noch
einmal in aller ruhe anschauen wie immer
online zusammengefasst auf zdf heute.de
und in der zdf- heute- app so bleiben
sie immer am ball
das corona virus breitet sich in der
deutschen eishockey liga aus bei red
bull münchen wurden inzwischen 22 fälle
gemeldet das gesundheitsamt hat eine
quarantäne für spieler und betreuer
verhängt ebenso betroffen die
düsseldorfer eg nach mehreren fällen in
der mannschaft die spieler beider teams
am wochenende werden verlegt
triumph für deutschland bei der
bahnrad-wm in ruby pauline grabosch emma
hintze und lea-sophie friedrich siegen
im team sprint vor russland erstmals bei
diesem wettbewerb drei athletinnen am
start
nicht nur das gold strahlt und nicht nur
über den titel gleich drei mal hat das
deutsche team im bahnrad velodrom von
roubaix den weltrekord geknackt am ende
46,0 64 sekunden für emma hintze
silbermedaillengewinnerin von tokio ist
die wm-titelverteidigung eine genugtuung
wir waren die letzten weltmeister im
zweier team jetzt sind wir die ersten zu
dritt echt klasse
morgen hat sie die nächste
medaillenchance im sprint
das wassersport danke norbert
sammelleidenschaft kann ja manchmal
ziemlich kostspielig werden seine
dinosaurier begeisterung hat sie ein
unbekannter bieter aus den usa heute
halten sie sich fest 6,6 millionen euro
kostenlos kosten lassen das skelett des
größten triceratops der welt wurde in
paris versteigert big john lebte vor
rund 66 millionen jahren und ist acht
meter lang aber künftig das haus des
sammlers ziert oder doch ein museum zur
verfügung gestellt wird ist noch nicht
klar
nach dem sturm ist vor dem nächsten
sturm aber der wirt zahna und trifft
nicht alle die details gleich von katja
honnef das heute-journal können sie mit
marietta slomka um 21.45 sehen und
morgen begrüßt hier an dieser stelle
barbara hahlweg macht sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend innerhalb von 24 stunden ist
das sturmtief über den ärmelkanal und
deutschland weitergezogen bis zur ostsee
es brachte kräftige schauer und gewitter
mit und viel wind zum glück sind die
orkane jetzt aus deutschland heraus
heute nacht kann es allenfalls noch
sturmböen an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee geben und verloren sie noch
einige schauer und gewitter rhein an den
alpen fällt noch etwas regen dazwischen
aber lockern die wolken zum teil auf
besonders hier in der eifel und unter
dem klaren sternenhimmel sinken dort die
temperaturen auf null grad dort droht
also bodenfrost wie verbreitet in der
mitte deutschlands
sonst liegen die temperaturen bei 9 bis
4 grad und morgen ist es deutlich kälter
als heute uns erwarten höchsttemperatur
ufern 7 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und maximal 13 grad am
oberrhein und das wetter ist im
wesentlichen zwei zeit abgesehen von
letzten schauern am alpenrand zeigt sich
in süddeutschland morgen häufig die
sonne das wird also ein freundlicher
freitag im norden dagegen gibt es
schauer zum teil auch gewitter unter
bläst der wind noch mal stark bis
stürmisch die gute aussicht zum schluss
ist das wochenende wird deutlich ruhiger
sonne und wolken wechseln sich ab zum
teil hält sich nebel auch mal ca und
dann wird es schon wieder milder guten
abend